simon vigneault la femme qui a fait
tomber le bastion socialiste en 1993 sur
les terres de françois mitterrand l'élu
rpr alors âgé de 50 ans créé la surprise
et remporte l'élection législative elle
devient la première femme députée élue
dans la nièvre psychologue scolaire de
profession elle sera notamment chargée
durant son mandat d'un rapport sur la
représentation féminine dans les manuels
scolaires
né en 1943 à vichy dans l'allier si
mourinho aura marqué la vie politique
bourguignonne durant plus de quarante
ans dont 25 à occuper ce siège celui de
maire de saint-honoré-les-bains petite
commune de 750 habitants
femme de terrain connu pour son franc
parler
si mourinho avait passé la main en 2014
elle est décédée brutalement hier à
l'âge de 75 ans